the stoics do emphasize a kind of
Detachment in life to accept things as
they come since they are the workings of
God and then to be equally happy to let
them go once the time comes and perhaps
above all to let go of things that we
cannot control stoicism is thus very
much a philosophy of self-control one is
to use one's reason that faculty of
oneself that is divine after all and
align it to the general reason or logos
of the whole and this also means
avoiding what the stoics call Passions
life is full of such passions or
emotions and they are often divided into
four General categories distress fear
lust and Delight each of these of course
have subcategories of passions or
emotions that should be avoided or
controlled things like anger lust
jealousy sadness Envy Etc to the stoics
the passions are essentially
misunderstandings or false attributions
of value